Il y a quelques jours de cela, nous avons eu la joie de fêter la Noël.
Et à cette occasion, notre pasteur David a fait un excellent travail.
Il nous a exposé le mystère de la piété.
Il nous a rappelé que la Noël est au cœur de la vraie piété
et que sa célébration avait tout à voir avec la bonté d'un Dieu qui se révèle dans toute sa gloire.
Et l'idée même que le monde s'approprie cette fête, certes en la dénaturant,
ne doit pas nous pousser à la rejeter,
mais plutôt à saisir une occasion unique d'exposer le mystère de l'incarnation,
c'est-à-dire le fait que Dieu endosse notre nature humaine et vienne parmi nous.
Imaginez donc un moment que l'apôtre Jean soit ici avec nous,
qu'il ait traversé la fête de Noël comme vous et moi.
Que nous dirait-il ?
Je crois savoir.
Il nous dirait.
Au commencement était la parole.
Et la parole était avec Dieu.
Et la parole était Dieu.
En elle était au commencement avec Dieu.
Toutes choses ont été faites par elle.
Et rien de ce qui a été fait n'a été fait sans elle.
Et la parole a été faite chère.
Et elle a habité parmi nous, pleine de grâce et de vérité.
Et nous avons contemplé sa gloire comme la gloire du Fils unique venu du Père.
C'est une révélation incroyable que nous fait l'apôtre Jean.
En nous dévoilant ce mystère qu'est l'incarnation.
Un dévoilement de la gloire de Dieu qui brille sur la face de son Fils Jésus-Christ.
Il n'y a aucune hésitation dans le propos de Jean.
Qui que vous soyez,
quel que soit ce que vous pensez,
il ne s'excuse pas en prenant des tournus,
mais il proclame clairement,
dès le début de son évangile,
tel un héros fidèle
que le Dieu,
Esprit éternel,
tout-puissant et infini,
est devenu un homme et a exposé la gloire de Dieu.
Il a exposé cette gloire
à un monde hostile à lui.
Et malgré cette hostilité,
sa gloire a été vue
et elle a été contemplée
comme la gloire du Fils unique venu du Père.
Mes frères et sœurs,
l'apôtre ne désire pas seulement partager avec nous une nouvelle information,
à ajouter à nos connaissances.
Il ne désire pas non plus nous donner des révélations
qui nous laisseraient apathiques,
qui nous donneraient d'être dans une léthargie.
Mais comme le dit A.W. Tozer,
le gros bon sens devrait nous faire comprendre
que si ce que nous croyons
ne change rien à notre vie,
alors cela ne fait aucune différence pour Dieu non plus.
Mais ce que désire l'apôtre,
c'est que nous ajoutions foi
à cette vérité.
Il veut, en nous révélant cette vérité,
que nous croyons que Jésus est le Christ,
qu'il est le Christ de Dieu,
le Fils du Dieu vivant,
et qu'en croyant cela,
nous ayons la vie éternelle.
Cette vie éternelle qui nous introduit
dans l'intimité d'une relation
avec les trois personnes de la Trinité,
en communion avec le Père,
en communion avec le Fils,
et en communion avec le Saint-Esprit,
jusqu'à dans l'éternité.
C'est le but que vise l'apôtre Jean
dans son évangile qu'il nous présente.
Et c'est le but qui est le nôtre.
Chaque fois que nous témoignons
de l'évangile de Jésus-Christ
à une personne,
nous sommes devenus ses disciples.
Nous avons reçu grâce sur grâce.
Nous avons cru en Jésus.
Et nous voulons aussi
que d'autres aient foi en cette vérité
et embrassent cette vérité,
qu'il est le redempteur
et le sauveur du monde.
Rappelons-nous,
Christ a promis de ne mettre dehors
personne qui viendrait à lui.
S'appuyons sur cette promesse,
nous faisons les fonctions
d'ambassadeur pour Christ,
comme si Dieu exhortait par nous,
suppliant tout homme
à être réconcilié avec Dieu.
Ainsi, frères et sœurs,
c'est avec cet objectif en tête
et surtout poussé par le Saint-Esprit
que Jean écrit son évangile.
Ce qu'il a à dire
est glorieux.
est trop excellent.
Il expose,
dès le début de son évangile,
une des doctrines
les plus centrales
des Écritures,
à savoir
la divinité de Jésus-Christ.
Jésus,
le Christ,
est Seigneur.
Il continue encore
en voulant être précis
et concis,
en s'adressant
à tous les hommes,
sans exception.
Il vise tout homme.
Grégoire des Nazions
dit
« Matthieu a écrit
pour les Hébreux,
Marc a écrit
pour les Italiens,
Luc a écrit
pour les Grecs,
et le grand héros Jean
a écrit
pour tous,
c'est-à-dire
toutes les personnes
qui sont
dans cette salle
et qui nous écoutent
et qui nous entendent.
Ne perdons donc
pas trop de temps
puisque cet évangile
a été écrit pour nous.
profitons,
plongeons-nous
sur l'étude
du verset 6
au verset 13
du chapitre 1.
Nous verrons
en première partie
le témoin fidèle
de la lumière,
puis en deuxième partie
le monde déchu
qui rejette la lumière
et nous conclurons
par le triomphe
de la lumière
dans le cœur
des enfants de Dieu.
et nous verrons
les enfants de Dieu.
verset 13
!
verset 14
verset 15
il est clair qu'il fait référence à Christ
il n'y a pas à hésiter
la lumière c'est Christ
et c'est ce que Jésus dit de lui-même
!
je suis la lumière du monde
celui qui me suit
ne marchera pas dans les ténèbres
mais il aura
la lumière
de vie
de la vie
Jean 8
verset 12
la lumière c'est Christ
et c'est ce que nous avons chanté ce matin
Christ est la lumière du monde
il est la manifestation suprême
de la présence de Dieu
l'image invisible du Dieu
l'image visible du Dieu invisible
Christ est la lumière
et la source de toute lumière spirituelle
chaleur
vie
santé
croissance
beauté
fertilité
Christ regroupe tout cela
comme le soleil
il brille pour le bien commun de l'humanité
pour les pauvres
et les riches
pour les juifs
et les grecs
il est la lumière
qui est de toute égalité
et cette lumière
est venue dans le monde
cette lumière brille
de telle sorte
qu'il est impossible
de la contempler
et de passer à côté
de l'éclat
de sa gloire
impossible
de rencontrer Christ
et de ne pas
voir sa gloire
remarquez encore
Jésus appelle Jean Baptiste
la lampe qui brûle
et qui lui
et Jean Baptiste appelle Jésus
la véritable
lumière
Jean est une chandelle
Jésus est un feu
Jean Baptiste est un rayon
de soleil
et Jésus Christ
est le soleil
de justice
et ce soleil
était dans ce monde
éclairant tout homme
en dehors de Christ
il n'y a point de lumière
pour des pécheurs
aucun pécheur
aucun
pas un seul
ne peut avoir de la lumière
nous lisons
verset 10
non
plutôt
et ce soleil
de justice
a quitté
son ciel de gloire
ce soleil
de justice
a éclairé
tout homme
mais quelle
fut la réponse
que nous lui avons donnée
quand ce soleil
a resplendi
dans le monde
quelle attitude
avons-nous eu
envers la lumière
nous lisons
verset 10
que nous avons eu
une attitude
de réjet
de mépris
elle était
dans le monde
et le monde
a été fait par elle
ne l'a point connue
verset 10
il s'agit ici
de l'état
d'incredulité
du monde
avant l'incarnation
de Christ
en effet
les évidences
de la providence
et des œuvres
de Christ
qui a créé
ce monde
sont visibles
et nous sommes
inexcusables
de ne pas les reconnaître
la lumière
a été comme
une bougie
qui brille
dans un lieu
sombre
comme une lumière
au milieu
des ténèbres
rendant les ténèbres
encore plus visibles
et c'est la même vérité
que l'apôtre Paul
expose dans le livre
aux Romains
quand il dit
les perfections
invisibles de Dieu
sa puissance éternelle
sa divinité
se voient
comme à l'œil
depuis la création
du monde
quand on les considère
dans ses ouvrages
ils sont donc
inexcusables
puisqu'ayant connu Dieu
ils ne l'ont point
glorifié comme Dieu
ils ne lui ont point
rendu grâce
mais ils se sont égarés
dans leurs pensées
et leur cœur
sans intelligence
a été plongé
dans les ténèbres
ce n'était pas
un manque de lumière
il a créé le monde
tout témoigne de lui
frères et sœurs
c'est l'une des plus
grandes vérités
et des plus importantes
vérités des écritures
nous avons
une nature
corrompue
qui nous empêche
de nous tourner
vers Dieu
de nous-mêmes
elle nous empêche
de l'admirer
comme la source
de tout
bien suprême
et de l'aimer
de tout notre cœur
de toute notre pensée
et de toute notre force
comme nos premiers parents
après leur désobéissance
nous nous cachons
de la face de Dieu
au son de sa voix
l'auteur des proverbes
ajoute
qu'au brucement
d'une feuille
le méchant
prend la fuite
la Bible nous identifie
comme les méchants
mais bien aimé
à ce stade
il est nécessaire
que nous comprenions
un point important
sur la nature humaine
dans les écritures
le cœur humain
est plus que l'organe
qui nous sert
à vivre
le cœur
est le centre
de tout
ce que nous sommes
le siège
de notre volonté
et de nos émotions
et cette volonté
est interdépendante
de notre nature
imaginons un instant
que notre nature
soit un cavalier
et notre volonté
un cheval
c'est le cavalier
qui guidera
le cheval
si donc
notre nature
qui est le cavalier
est mauvaise
notre volonté
qui est le cheval
ira dans la mauvaise direction
et cette direction
est donnée
par le cavalier
un mauvais cavalier
entraînera
nécessairement
le cheval
avec lui
nature
et volonté
sont interdépendants
et tout homme
né d'Adam
a hérité
de cette nature
corrompue
et nous ne pouvons pas
la changer
de nous-mêmes
c'est impossible
la Bible
en témoigne
comprenons bien
que cette nature
est liée
au péché
originel
alors
il faut définir
pour nous
qu'est-ce que le péché
originel
nous avons besoin
de le comprendre
le péché originel
ne fait pas référence
au premier péché
d'Adam et Ève
comme on l'entend souvent
le péché originel
c'est le résultat
du péché
d'Adam et Ève
eux qui avaient été créés
dans un état de justice
avec un cœur
incliné
à aimer Dieu
après leur offense
ont vu
leur nature
leur cœur
se corrompre
créés
avec un cœur
incliné
à aimer Dieu
ayant péché
nature
corrompue
totalement
frères et sœurs
la corruption
de notre nature
est trop grande
un orthopien
peut-il changer
sa peau
un léopard
s'étache
de même
pourriez-vous
faire le bien
vous qui êtes
accoutumés
à faire le mal
voilà
ce monde
qui n'a point
connu
la lumière
et qui est
sans excuse
mais la tragédie
ne s'arrête pas là
comme une spirale
notre corruption
a entraîné
ce monde
dans un abîme
sans fin
c'est pourquoi
la peau de Jean
continue en affirmant
aussi au verset 11
que la lumière
est venue
chez les siens
et les siens
ne l'ont point reçu
ici
Jean veut que nous
considérions
notre état
d'hostilité
devant la présence
de la lumière
et principalement
l'hostilité
du peuple juif
lorsque la lumière
a ajouté
à sa nature divine
la nature humaine
quel accueil
lui ont réservé
les siens
c'est-à-dire
les juifs
comment l'ont
ils accueillis
la réponse
se trouve
à Golgotha
à la croix
du calvaire
où les siens
ont pris
le fils de Dieu
et avec une haine
en conformité
à la rébellion
de leur cœur
contre Dieu
ils l'ont
humilié
placardé
cloué
sur ce bois
maudit
ils l'ont
rejeté
et ils l'ont
tué
il vint
vers un peuple
qui lui appartenait
particulièrement
un peuple
qu'il possédait
lui-même
par leur rédemption
en Égypte
leur introduction
dans la terre
promise
Canaan
leur possession
de la loi
de Moïse
et des alliances
un peuple
qui possédait
les oracles
de Dieu
Frère et soeur
le monde
pouvait rejeter
la lumière
mais certainement
pas les juifs
pas le peuple
de Dieu
le peuple juif
avec tant de privilèges
ce n'était pas possible
et pourtant
les siens
l'ont condamné
à la crucifixion
c'est avec raison
que le cœur naturel
est appelé
des expériment
méchants
et surtout
ne nous méprions pas
Frères et soeurs
nous qui ne sommes pas
juifs
bien que les siens
ne se réfèrent pas
particulièrement
à nous
l'apôtre Pierre
nous rappelle
que nous étions
bien représentés
lors de ce crime
au Dieu
en effet
quand on
on
ton saint serviteur
Jésus
que tu as
on
Hérode
et Ponce Pilate
se sont ligués
dans cette ville
avec les nations
et avec
les peuples
d'Israël
pour faire
tout ce que
ta main
et ton conseil
avaient arrêté
d'avance
oui nous avons
été présents
nous avons tué
le Christ
nous avons
rejeté la lumière
du monde
juif
non juif
le monde
parrain
était bien
représenté
notre aveuglement
devant
la gloire
du Christ
est aussi
coupable
que celui
des juifs
bien que
le Christ
dispense
à chacun
une lumière
suffisante
pour laisser
tous
les peuples
sans excuses
nous sommes
véritablement
sans excuses
devant ce rejet
du Christ
ce rejet
de la lumière
toutefois
ce sont nos souffrances
qu'il a porté
à cette croix
c'est de nos douleurs
qu'il s'est chargé
!
il était blessé
pour nos péchés
brisé
pour nos iniquités
le châtiment
qui nous donne
la paix
est tombé sur lui
nous étions tous
errants
comme des vrais vies
chacun suivait
sa propre voie
et l'éternel
a fait retomber
sur lui
l'iniquité
de nous tous
il a été
maltraité
et opprimé
il n'a point
ouvert la bouche
semblable à un agneau
qu'on mène
à la boucherie
à une brébille
muillette
devant ceux
qui l'attendent
il n'a point
ouvert la bouche
il n'a plus
à l'éternel
de le briser
par la souffrance
les frères et soeurs
Dieu a pris
cependant
le contre-pied
du verdict
des hommes
en ressuscitant
le Christ
et en sauvant
son peuple
au travers
du crime
le plus effroyable
jamais commis
et bien que ce rejet
est tourné
à l'avantage
de tous ceux
qui croient
en Christ
il n'est pas
moins abominable
il a mis en évidence
notre corruption
totale
mais à tous ceux
qui l'ont reçu
à ceux qui croient
en son nom
elle a donné le pouvoir
de devenir
enfant
de Dieu
c'est ce que
Jean nous dit
au verset 12
frères et soeurs
jamais un mot
n'aura été
si déterminant
pour mettre en évidence
la grâce de Dieu
dans le salut
des pécheurs
que le mot
mais
nous le retrouvons
dans plusieurs passages
qui explicitent
l'oeuvre du salut
de Dieu
chez les croyants
comme dans
Ephésiens 2
que Nat nous a lus
ce matin
où il est dit
mais c'est pas grâce
que vous êtes sauvés
et l'apôtre
dit tout cela
après un long exposé
de notre corruption
mais c'est pas grâce
que vous êtes sauvés
vous étiez morts
mais c'est pas grâce
que vous êtes sauvés
Jean utilise
donc cette conjonction
de coordination
mais
pour mettre en contraste
notre réjet
de la lumière
et son efficacité
en effet
notre réjet
n'a jamais
affaibli
un seul yotard
un seul instant
l'éclat de la lumière
jamais
au contraire
la lumière
a triomphé
des ténèbres
avec une telle puissance
qu'elle est allée
jusqu'à rendre
des enfants de colère
enfants de Dieu
quel triomphe
de la lumière
il nous apparaît
devant ces versets
que croire en Christ
ou avoir
la foi en Christ
est plus qu'une
acceptation
à inviter Jésus
dans nos cœurs
ou répéter
une prière
du salut
après quelqu'un
la foi en Christ
d'une manière
salvatrice
requiert la connaissance
cette connaissance
se réfère
au contenu
de la foi
aux vérités
que nous croyons
il y a certaines choses
que nous devons
croire au sujet
des Christ
comme par exemple
qu'il est le fils
de Dieu
et Jean nous le rappelle
dans son évangile
qu'il est notre sauveur
il est mort à la croix
pour nos péchés
s'identifier à lui
qu'il a prouvé
à l'expiation
il a effacé
nos fautes
il a apaisé
la colère de Dieu
nous devons croire
certaines choses
son œuvre
et sa personne
mais la foi en Christ
qui sauve
ne s'arrête pas là
ne s'arrête pas
à la connaissance
elle exige
un assentiment
c'est-à-dire
la conviction
que le contenu
de notre foi
est vrai
quelqu'un peut connaître
la foi chrétienne
et pourtant
croit qu'elle n'est pas vraie
donc connaître
ne nous sauve pas
aussi pouvons-nous avoir
un ou deux doutes
mêlés à notre foi
mais il doit y avoir
un certain niveau
d'affirmation intellectuelle
et de conviction
si nous voulons être sauvés
la foi authentique
et véritable
dit que
le contenu
c'est-à-dire
la connaissance
est vraie
en plus de cette connaissance
et conviction
notre foi
a d'être accompagné
d'une confiance personnelle
et une dépendance
à Christ
nous devons nous confier
les démons peuvent connaître
et croire le contenu
de la foi chrétienne
l'âtre disait un jour
qu'il y a plus de vérité
qui sort dans la bouche
des démons
que de certains pasteurs
et c'est vrai
ils connaissent la vérité
mais ils ne se confient pas
au Christ
pour leur salut
la foi n'est efficace
que si nous avons
personnellement confiance
en Christ
en se reposant
sur sa personne
et son oeuvre parfaite
c'est très important
nous ne sommes sauvés
quand nous confions seulement
en la personne
et en l'oeuvre de Jésus Christ
il y a toutefois
un dernier élément
qui n'est pas
des moindres
quand nous parlons
de la foi authentique
c'est l'affection
Frères et Sœurs
une personne
qui n'est pas née de nouveau
ne viendra jamais à Jésus
la raison est simple
elle ne voudra pas de lui
certes
elle peut vouloir
ses bienfaits
mais elle ne voudra pas
de Jésus
dans son cœur
dans son esprit
comment un cœur de pierre
pourrait-il réagir
à la beauté de Christ
comment
un cœur de pierre
Satan est un bon exemple
Satan connait la vérité
mais il la déteste
il n'a aucune envie
d'adorer Dieu
parce qu'il ne l'aime pas
il n'a aucune affection
à part la haine
ainsi un cœur non régénéré
sans l'action
de l'esprit de Dieu
est sans vie
sans amour
1 Corinthiens 2
11 à 14
nous dit
lequel des hommes
en effet
connaît les choses
de l'homme
si ce n'est l'esprit
qui est en lui
l'esprit de l'homme
connaît les choses
de l'homme
de même
personne ne connaît
les choses de Dieu
si ce n'est l'esprit
de Dieu
comment
un homme sans l'esprit
de Dieu
connaîtra les choses
l'esprit de l'homme
connaît les choses
de l'homme
l'esprit de Dieu
connaît les choses
de Dieu
or nous n'avons pas
reçu
l'esprit du monde
mais l'esprit
qui vient de Dieu
pourquoi
afin que nous
connaissions les choses
que Dieu nous a données
par sa grâce
comment quelqu'un peut voir
la beauté de Christ
la gloire de Christ
comment quelqu'un peut apprécier
le salut
le fait d'être
un jour
dans la gloire
avec Christ
autour d'une table
en train de
de fêter
la joie
de racheter
c'est impossible
sans l'esprit de Dieu
et nous en parlons
avec des discours
qu'enseigne la sagesse humaine
mais
non avec les discours
qu'enseigne la sagesse humaine
pardon
mais avec
ceux qu'enseigne l'esprit
!
employant un langage spirituel
pour les choses spirituelles
vous faites tous l'expérience
des discussions
avec des personnes
vous voyez
que ce n'est pas un problème
de conviction
ce n'est pas un problème
d'argumentation
mais l'homme
animal
ou l'homme naturel
ne reçoit pas
les choses de l'esprit
dites moi
comment un homme
qui n'est pas né de nouveau
peut recevoir les choses
de l'esprit
comment un homme
né d'Adam
nature corrompue
que nous venons d'exposer
peut recevoir
les choses de Dieu
c'est impossible
car elles sont une folie
pour lui
il ne peut les connaître
parce que c'est spirituellement
qu'on en juge
capacité
il ne peut
Jésus dit
il ne peut même pas
voir le royaume des cieux
ses yeux sont incapables
de voir le royaume des cieux
incapables de voir
s'il ne voit pas
comment il va entrer
impossible d'y entrer
s'il ne naît de nouveau
Frères et sœurs
c'est à ce stade
que nous pouvons apprécier
d'une manière émerveillée
le triomphe
de la grâce de Dieu
qui nous a conduit
à croire
et c'est en comprenant
la nécessité
de la régénération
que chantaient
les louanges
de sa grâce
prend un sens particulier
dans nos cœurs de racheté
et c'est ce que nous avons
chanté ce matin
il a triomphé
de nos ténèbres
il a percé
le cœur de pierre
là où il y a foi
il y a toujours
une nouvelle naissance
et là où il n'y a pas foi
il n'y a pas de régénération
soyez-en sûr
on ne peut pas séparer
Christ et ses bienfaits
nous devons comprendre
aussi
ce que l'apôtre
entend
par elle a donné
le pouvoir
de devenir
enfant de Dieu
ce verset est très
connu
il est utilisé
pour raconter
tout
et son contraire
le mot pouvoir
utilisé ici
ne veut pas dire
capacité
ou force
cela ne veut pas dire
que Christ confère
à ceux qui le reçoivent
une force spirituelle
et morale
par laquelle
ils se convertissent
eux-mêmes
change leur propre cœur
et se font
enfant de Dieu
ce n'est pas ce que ce mot
veut dire
le mot pouvoir
signifie seulement
que Christ confère
le privilège
le grand privilège
de l'adoption
à tous les croyants
adopté
par Dieu
et si lorsque nous croyons
authentiquement
en Christ
pour notre salut
Christ nous confère
le privilège
de l'adoption
dans la famille de Dieu
nous devenons
enfants de Dieu
par la foi
en Jésus Christ
seul
si vous êtes dans cette salle
ce matin
si vous nous écoutez
et que vous n'avez pas
mis votre confiance
en Jésus Christ
votre foi
c'est de la présomption
de vous faire
appeler
enfant de Dieu
c'est de la présomption
de croire
que vous êtes
enfant de Dieu
cela n'a
aucune valeur
tant bien
que vous le crierez
sur tous les toits
avec toutes vos forces
c'est de la présomption
cela restera
de la présomption
de croire
que vous êtes
réconciliés
avec Dieu
il vous voit
toujours
comme ses ennemis
et son feu
est préparé
vous attend
c'est pour cela
frères et sœurs
ceux qui ne croient pas
encore en Christ
c'est pour cela
que nous plaidons
avec vous
soyez réconciliés
avec Dieu
au travers de la répentance
et de la foi
en Jésus Christ
il a subi le réjet
il saura vous accueillir
il a subi la mort
il saura vous donner la vie
il est maintenant
couronné de gloire
il sera triomphé
de vos ténèbres
par sa grâce
fils ne nous mettra pas
dehors
sinon vous venez à lui
vous ne serez jamais confus
en vous représentant
sa personne
et en son œuvre parfaite
si en revanche
vous êtes assis ici
ce matin
et que vous avez
mis votre confiance
pour cette vie
et celle à venir
en Jésus Christ
vous pouvez avoir
avec certitude
une assurance
que vous êtes
enfant de Dieu
vous avez des frères
et des sœurs
dans le ciel
qui rendent gloire
continuellement à Dieu
vous avez des frères
et des sœurs
dans cette salle
avec qui vous assemblez
et vous chantez
les louanges
et la gloire de Dieu
vous avez des frères
et des sœurs
partout dans le monde
qui se rassemblent
pour exalter Christ
vous avez des frères
et des sœurs
vous avez toute la légitimité
d'appeler Dieu
votre père
vous avez reçu
l'esprit d'adoption
il crie en vous
à ma paix
et certainement
le Dieu des cieux
le roi des rois
assis sur son trône
il vous répond
!
ma fille
mon fils
chaque fois que vous l'appelez
les pères
les grands
nos privilèges
vous êtes sa famille
vous êtes de lui
quel honneur
quel bonheur
quel don précieux
voilà notre joie
voilà notre espérance
mais
Dieu
frères et sœurs
ne nous me prénons pas
il y a quelque chose
qui a vraiment fait une différence
pour que nous soyons comptés
parmi les enfants de Dieu
il y a quelque chose
qui a fait une différence
ce n'est pas notre intelligence
c'est à dire
nos facultés à raisonner
et à discerner
non
pas du tout
ce n'est pas notre volonté
c'est à dire
la force de nos résolutions
nous savons bien
prenons des résolutions
chaque année
et c'est difficile de les tenir
souvent nous n'arrivons pas
donc ce n'est pas
la force de nos résolutions
si c'était le cas
on n'aurait pas aussi
pu attraper le Christ
ce n'est pas la force
de nos résolutions
ce n'est pas non plus
le lien de sang
c'est à dire
le fait d'être né
d'un parent croyant
non
mais la raison
la seule
l'unique
pour des chrétiens
se trouve dans la grâce
souveraine libre
et rayonnante de Dieu
Dieu d'une main puissante
d'une force triomphante
perça la pierre
de mon coeur
aride
nous avons chanté
ce matin
Dieu lui-même
est intervenu
par son esprit éternel
et nous a appliqué
les mérites de Christ
pour que nous soyons appelés
enfants de Dieu
et si lorsque nous étions encore
sans force
Christ est mort
pour des impies
il n'est pas mort
pour des justes
il est mort
pour des impies
et c'est par sa grâce
que nous sommes sauvés
c'est par grâce
que maintenant
nous vivons
par le moyen
de la foi
et cela ne vient pas
de nous
c'est le don
gratuit
d'un Dieu
trinitaire
qui est bon
aimant
et qui nous a fait grâce
lui seul
la souveraine
libre grâce
de Dieu
frères et sœurs
a traversé
l'éternité passée
s'est introduite
dans le temps
et dans l'histoire
pour opérer
une rédemption
éternelle
afin de nous
transporter
dans l'éternité
future
pour une gloire
dans la présence
du Dieu trinitaire
vous voyez
le fil
de la grâce
de Dieu
travaillant
transversant
le temps
l'espace
pour nous ramener
à la gloire
c'est en résumé
ce que nous révèle
Jean lorsqu'il dit
lesquels sont nés
non du sang
ni de la volonté
de la chair
de l'homme
mais de Dieu
verset 13
il y a un grand rappel
pour nous au travers
de ces passages
c'est que nous sommes
nés de Dieu
nous avons goûté
sa puissance
de résurrection
et c'est la raison
pour laquelle
nous sommes appelés
enfants de Dieu
maintenant que nous vivons
soyons des témoins fidèles
des témoins fidèles
du grand roi
qui nous a enrôlés
une nuitée
des témoins fidèles
nous entoure aussi
emboîtons-leur le pas
en comptant sur sa toute puissance
et sa grâce
mes frères et sœurs
n'oublions pas non plus
le but pour lequel
Jean a écrit cette lettre
cet évangile
pardon
il a écrit
pour que nous puissions croire
que Jésus
est le fils de Dieu
et qu'en croyant
chacun
tous ceux
qui font cette expérience
puissent avoir
la vie éternelle
alors répondons
avec foi
répondons
avec empressement
ce témoignage
est puissant
c'est le Saint-Esprit
qui le donne
lui-même
de Christ
ajoutons
à cette vérité
notre foi
faisons-lui confiance
pour nos pèlerinages
terrestres
faisons-lui confiance
pour nos regards
à la gloire
car le Christ
la véritable lumière
a triomphé
d'un ténèbre
de nos cœurs
pour faire de nous
des enfants de Dieu
et